et on va parler tout de suite de rugby à
5 on commençait à en parler à tout à
l'heure en début d'émission la chambre
des métiers de l'artisanat est
l'Île-de-France lance sa deuxième
édition du Trophée mixte de rugby à 5
autres au total 96 joueurs et joueurs
joueuses et joueurs des apprentis de 8
centres de formation de la région vont
s'affronter à ce jeudi 20 avril à
Marcoussis au Centre National de Rugby
c'est le la capitale de du rugby en
France avec le CFA de Versailles qui est
notamment de la partie on en parle avec
Mathieu Berrier qui est toujours avec
nous chef de travaux coach de l'équipe
du Centre de formation des apprentis de
Versailles et à vos côtés nous a rejoint
également Brice Hernandez bonsoir vous
êtes vous apprentis donc au CFA de
Versailles et vous faites partie donc de
cette équipe mixte de rugby A5
l'objectif de ce tournoi Mathieu Berrier
qui est utile c'est de promouvoir
l'apprentissage promouvoir la pratique
du rugby mixte aussi l'entraîne en fait
on a une association qui s'est faite
avec la Ligue de
et donc en fait depuis la deuxième c'est
la deuxième saison là qu'on fait et donc
pour pouvoir promouvoir le rugby
promouvoir aussi les jeunes qui puissent
aller vers le rugby parce que c'est
quand même un sport qui est pas
forcément qui fait peur certainement
donc le toucher ça permet d'attirer
beaucoup de jeunes comme brise par
exemple qui vient qui connaît pas du
tout le rugby qui a pris les règles en
deux mois et qui va faire le tournoi
jeudi prochain et encore le remporter
j'espère pour Versailles confirmer Brice
vous me connaissez rien du du rugby à la
base pas du tout alors qu'est-ce qui
vous a attiré justement dans la pratique
du rugby touché
justement le fait qu'il y ait pas de
placage et que ça soit pas
si je peux dire brut comme le rugby
classique et puis voilà
promouvoir aussi on imagine les valeurs
d'un sport qui est le rugby aussi vous
êtes vous-même pratiquant vous jouez il
me semble au plaisir Rugby Club en plus
c'est ça
mais c'est quoi les valeurs du rugby je
vais faire réagir mes invités autour de
la table Cyril les valeurs du rugby
la solidarité à la base je pense que
c'est plus c'est très intéressant sur
les écoles de rugby c'est
l'épanouissement la vie de groupe et
avec un peu de compétition bien sûr mais
c'est quand même ces valeurs là et puis
de solidarité entre eux Bastien le voit
tous les dimanches sur le net sur les
terrains
là plaisir justement on a vraiment des
grosses valeurs de solidarité et cette
année c'est ça qui nous a amené à avoir
de si bons résultats d'ailleurs mettre
en avant aussi des projets pédagogiques
c'est aussi ça l'objectif aussi la
pédagogie on a le sport déjà aussi au
niveau du CFA parce que en étant
apprenti certains métiers comme la
boulangerie la pâtisserie bon moi
forcément pour quelques kilos donc c'est
bien aussi que les jeunes fasse du sport
on a des coiffeuses on a des
esthéticiennes qui viennent aussi jouer
avec nous donc franchement c'est tous
les métiers qui peuvent participer tous
les CFA de l'Île-de-France justement
vont pouvoir participer et se rencontrer
jour là ça vous fait quoi brise de jouer
au Centre national du rugby alors je
disais tout à l'heure la capitale du
rugby c'est là où l'équipe de France de
rugby s'entraîne je vais fâcher nos amis
du Sud-Ouest mais en tout cas c'est un
c'est un centre c'est le Centre national
du rugby ça vous fait quoi de pouvoir
fouler ces pelouses et de jouer pour ce
tournoi là-bas
je sais pas trop j'ai jamais été donc
je serai pas vos réponses pas de souci
mais ça vous tenait à cœur aussi de
pratiquer le rugby dans cette formule 1
un tournoi mixte oui je trouve ça super
que bah il est des filles qui puissent
jouer avec nous et comme c'est au
toucher bah ça va
des joueurs comme Brice qui ont
découvert le rugby du coup comment vous
les avez entraînés comment ça s'est
passé la préparation c'est eux qui ont
été
moteur en fait on a mis une inscription
tout le monde pouvait s'inscrire ils
sont venus de même il y a pas eu de
force forcer quelqu'un à venir après
première entraînement un peu difficile
ouais forcément on découvre on apprend
des règles on comprend pas forcément
tout mais ça se fait ça se fait très
bien les jeunes filles sont de plus en
plus motivés on a quand même Stéphanie
qui est aussi la deuxième année qui a
fait le tournoi on a un joueur de
l'année dernière qui a joué en équipe
bmapa plaisir dans le coup et qui refait
le tournoi cette année en deuxième année
en BTM parce que c'est la deuxième
édition vous l'aviez remporté la
dernière donc on remet nos petites en
jeu
on va certainement remporter
vous êtes confiant pour ce tournoi
est-ce que le niveau des autres CFA est
bon est-ce que vous savez à peu près le
niveau du tout non ça va être de la
découverte on sait que l'année dernière
on était au-dessus mais maintenant cette
année je pense qu'ils ont vu aussi ils
ont appris des règles ils ont sport
aussi nous malheureusement on fait pas
de sport au CFA avec on a pas de prof de
sport en fait donc c'est nous
gratuitement gracieusement avec amour
pour le rugby quand on participe à ça
aussi et il me semble que on amène cette
journée enfin en parallèle il y a aussi
deux concours il y a celui du meilleur
maillot le meilleur haka également c'est
ça vous allez travailler aussi là dessus
du coup Brice oui avec une
fille de ma classe qui participe au
rugby on a fait le maillot de notre
équipe et puis on a aussi a fait je
crois que c'est la semaine dernière on a
fait la
vidéo pour le concours du meilleur aka
donc là on imagine l'idée oui d'attirer
un peu plus les jeunes parce qu'en plus
c'est sur TikTok ce concours directement
alors très concrètement pour terminer ça
va se passer comment la journée de jeudi
quel est le programme alors je dis c'est
arrivé à 9h à Marcoussis distribution de
leur maillots qu'ils ont pas encore vu
donc il va découvrir le vrai maillot ce
coup-ci qu'ils ont dessiné avec Cécilia
tous les toutes les équipes ont changé
après on commence de 10h à midi poule de
9 toutes les équipes se rencontrentes
donc c'est des matchs de deux fois 6
minutes et ensuite l'après-midi c'est
les phases finales premier contre après
je sais pas exactement comment ça va se
dérouler mais les phases finales
l'après-midi repas tous ensemble le midi
à la cantine de Marcoussis
et la finale le soir avant de partir et
remise des deux tous les
comment dire de tous les trophées
c'est une chance quand même Bastien et
de jouer à Marcoussis vous avez déjà vu
cette chanson
j'ai eu cette chance parce que j'étais
stop sien alors c'est et il y a 10 ans
déjà et à l'époque on avait cette cette
chance de pouvoir se faire nos
entraînements de rugby là-bas à
Marcoussis donc on y allait le mardi et
parfois le jeudi et nous prêtait même
une salle de cours pour faire la théorie
du rugby donc ouais je connais bien
l'installation incroyable nickel vous
avez peut-être une question
pas spécialement mais
peut-être pour pour ce tournoi là que
vous avez que vous allez faire
tout simplement qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que vous aimeriez apprendre de ce
tournoi peut-être
je sais pas trop mais j'ai déjà appris
que en fait le rugby c'était pas si
sauvage que ça malgré l'absence de
plaquettes mais non parce que je suis
quelqu'un qui a peur des ballons donc
c'était une chance pour moi de
surmonter mes peurs bon bravo en tout
cas pour cette initiative Merci à VOUS
Brice merci Mathieu également bon
tournoi à vous et allez Versailles pour
ce tournoi de rugby à 5 qui va se
dérouler donc ce jeudi du côté de
Marcoussis